we like many um
made most of our money from in-person
and live events and workshops and of
course that instantaneously disappeared
um and so we
like many were forced to pivot
and we took advantage of online learning
but we wanted to do it consistent with
our own values
we did live classes
because we wanted to retain some sort of
human connection as opposed to just on
demand classes
um we called up people who we knew who
work whose work we admired and we said
you're struggling too why don't you come
and do share your your genius on our
platform
and it became a very cooperative thing
but there's a few tactics that i learned
to get from a to b that were really
helpful that i never would have done if
i didn't have that extreme pressure so
one of the things we did is we shared
with the team the vision
which we had
and then we said to the whole team
uh we can't do this alone this is this
is literally a team effort and so what i
want is i want 15 ideas from each person
in the next 48 hours about how we can
deliver on that vision
and the team freaked out
15 ideas in 48 hours and if they wanted
to work in teams i was fine with that
um and i and and the reason for that is
um the pressure you know if i gave them
three weeks
well they would have all done the work
the 48 hours before anyway
so
you know uh
uh so that was academic but the
important thing was the reason for 15
ideas is because if i only ask for two
or three or three or four
those would be the same ideas i came up
with
um uh and i wanted it's the idea that 11
12 and 13 that were the brilliant ones
and when we came together to report out
we did it in sort of a unique way
i sort of gave this little speech where
i said okay
this is not a competition this is about
contribution
if one person has six amazing ideas and
you have none instead of being angry say
thank you because they just saved your
job because they had a great idea
also what i learned is that there's a
there's a difference between somebody
who has an idea and someone who's good
at executing an idea and the reality is
the most creative people in the team
that could come up with the ideas
weren't the best at executing them and
the ones that didn't have that many
ideas they were great at executing ideas
so it became really interesting and to
see who were my creators and who were my
executors from that one meeting
and we played boggle rules if you ever
played the game boggle if somebody else
has your word you just skip over it and
move on i said if somebody says your
idea don't bother saying well i had that
idea too i'm not keeping score i don't
care simply move on and tell me
something else on your list and we only
let people report out two or three ideas
at a time that way we could sort of get
a flavor and what ended up happening was
people would build on the ideas that
they heard and the set of ideas that we
had at the end
became our ideas nobody could claim them
anymore because we'd all sort of
tinkered with them
and then
we broke them into three buckets green
yellow and red
a green idea was an idea we could
execute with the money we had and we
could execute it within the week
a yellow idea was an idea that needed a
little more resource probably take a
week to a month and a red idea no matter
how good it was was too expensive or
take too long and we just parked it and
said we'll deal those one day and we
just took all our green ideas and
executed them